[Music]
look at how the great problems of the
queen and the monarchy in her lifetime
have been all about love and marriage
and sex
the question a lot of people here in
britain are asking this morning is
where's the queen
[Music]
it's like being brought up in a
monastery with glass walls everyone can
look in
and every moment of weakness it'll all
be seen and exposed and ridiculed
[Music]
the red lights off we are interviewing
larry adler bringing to prince we are
interviewing commander michael agustin
into the year in lady janet mary
[Music]
for the first time in her reign the
queen put family before duty
we could now be witnessing the end of
the monarchy and the reigning queen
could possibly be the last
[Music]
[Music]
she was being the princess
and working
very hard
he was still in the navy
[Music]
now in our innocence we thought this was
going to go on for a very long time
after all the king was quite young
there might have been 40 more years as
princess
[Music]
when we were on that commonwealth tour
and we were in kenya and the people of
kenya having the wedding present in the
little cigar a lot
we had a day out there to do to adjust
and rest and do things prince philip
went i went to sleep in a little room
that was off to one side
the queen was at a desk writing letter's
phone rang my colleague
said mike there's a
ghastly rumor going around that the king
has died
and they used it amongst all the press
people there and they were saying that
they'd heard
so i said well
martin that's frightening but i cannot
do a thing
on a rumor like that
i mean i just won't do anything and he
said no i'm not suggesting he should
darn went the phone
i saw a radio
on the shelf above me
and there's a door open to where the
queen is sitting so i shut the door and
switched on the radio
and hunted about the bbc and then i
could hear the bell
of um
big ben
i thought we need god
so my hair stood up a little bit more
this is london
it is with the greatest sorrow that we
make the following announcement
at 10 45 today
february the 6th 1952
that the king
passed peacefully away in his sleep
earlier this morning
and uh that was that so
there was drought into where prince
william was sleeping and told him
his
first reaction was one of
almost there's a huge way to hit him
[Music]
and he just stood there
silently in thought
the implications of the fact that she's
becoming the queen
[Music]
and then he
straightened himself up and he went in
to tell the queen
and she was
in you know weeping desperately for the
loss of her father
they walked up and down together
very close
and then she strengthened up
[Music]
fully uh conscious of the fact that she
was queen
and that she must tend to that affair
immediately
and she went into the desk that she'd
been working on and started to send all
these telegrams off around the
commonwealth and to
friendly countries like the united
states
[Music]
there was no time then for her
if she had wanted to
to grieve
and a very typical reaction actually she
said oh i'm so sorry
it means we forgot
to go home
[Music]
as the plane was about to touch down at
london airport
and the prime minister winston churchill
and my parents that you've noticed of
johnston and all the receiving lines of
the cabinet were drawn up there
in their black clothes
and she sort of leans across and looks
out and says oh god they sent the
hearses meaning that instead of her car
one of the big
black cars
and somehow the way she said when you
this 25 year old realized that the
end of her
private life had come
and that for the rest of her life
she would be about it bigger don't they
should die
[Music]
i asked you all
whatever your religion
to pray for me on the day of my
coronation
and as the storms of cheering surge with
the approaching procession along the
river here in contrast the abbey holds
its ancient peace
[Music]
i think what changed for the queen
at the moment that she succeeded her
father
was the sense that
she was on her own
i think that that's what really changed
for her
[Music]
she did have the enormous advantage of
being trained by her own father and i
think she must have enjoyed those
training sessions with papa because it
was something so special between those
two nobody else has it
i remember once saying to me that
my father told me i must always remember
that whatever i've said or did to anyone
that they would remember it
so that if i show disapproval they will
remember that i showed disapproval
therefore i i think she's very very
careful
not to give any sort of impression that
might be
construed of disapproval
[Music]
the duke of edinburgh comes to vow
lifelong allegiance to his queen
[Music]
she's the queen
and he
performs as the husband
so what does the husband do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
elizabeth
as princess and queen
has always been
guided by her sense of duty
[Music]
but it's one of the extraordinary things
about the queen is that
she fell in love
and married just about the first man she
met
[Music]
my father happened to be there when the
king and queen took the two girls to
dartmouth
when i think
princess elizabeth was only about 12
years old and
as prince philip was
almost the senior cadet
and of course this absolute greek god
and i think that the princess fell
headlong enough with him at that moment
the queen was too young nobody talked
about
falling in love
and remaining in love with that person
for the rest of her life i mean she was
a
child
but clearly he made a great impression
on her and the romance if you like
developed sort of rather gradually
[Music]
now it caused her parents
great anxiety
what parent wouldn't be anxious about a
daughter
who wants to marry the very first man
she's fallen in love with
[Music]
it was a matter of her personal
happiness it was a matter of the
stability of the crown
her parents in fact while accepting
philip and having philip because he was
after all a member of the family to stay
wouldn't let her actually get engaged
until she was over 21
several years after she wanted
because you know she wasn't just taking
on the man she thought she loved she was
taking on the man who had to shoulder
almost half the burden of the monarchy
[Music]
well i was this back to the party the
night before the wedding
the princess delivered
he was scared his face was white
this man just began to realize what he
was getting into
and now he finally doesn't like it
[Music]
it was very much a conventional
british
household he was very much the man of a
family he took the decisions
she looked up to him in that private
life obviously as princess she had a lot
of visual things to do but they were
still able with these two small children
to have this family group
[Music]
prince philippe was basically a man
and he was a big man
and he was a man's man too
i think
there must have been marriage
when it would have been
[Music]
pretty heavy for him to take
this extremely active
enthusiastic young man who's suffering
advice is so life is going to be taken
away from him and probably thinking
he'll become a yes man for the rest of
his life
that's really devastated their lives
actually it's america
could you tell me
what is your job in your own mind
well i've got one i'm self-employed
but you must have some clear idea of
what role you fulfill
in modern society
very difficult to answer
[Music]
the queen can't be
the wife anymore the mother she really
had very little time to be with her
children so prince philip
in a way sort of became the house
husband and he was the one that
looked after the children not actually
physically looked after them but he
organized them
[Music]
when she became queen they would see her
perhaps for half an hour in the morning
nine o'clock for half an hour and then
she would go off
for a week maybe a month maybe several
months but in a good week she might be
there in the evening and go up to see
them having their baths and sit on a
little guilt chair which will be brought
in by a lackey not take part in bath
time or splashing or anything like that
but just sit there rather and easily and
then dash away after half an hour
i don't think it was you know in that
prince phillip and indeed the queen was
significantly different to an awful lot
of upper middle class british parents
since that was the way
behaving you didn't cry in public you
don't cuddle
et cetera
life may be a lot more civilized but it
wasn't something peculiar to
prince charles's relationship with his
parents
and it wasn't
that anybody was being deliberately
unkind
or cold it was just that was the way you
you did things
what the queen and the dude did with
their children
boarding school that often had strict
discipline and didn't always produce
rounded human beings emotionally
at the end of the process
[Music]
you know she's really sacrificed her
family in a way
duty really what came before personal
happiness and she had her work and that
came first
[Music]
elizabeth and her younger sister
margaret were always very close as
children but both of them
knew
that in the end
elizabeth would be on the throne
and princess margaret would need to find
a role for herself i don't think she
ever really settled to that to be honest
[Music]
[Music]
the arrival of princess margaret and her
husband is greeted with a cheers the
crowd
the flashing lights
and nervous children
dignified bedlam rings
[Music]
most adults remember margaret growing up
with her sister and the two children
were as loved by americans as they were
by britons
[Music]
the british and european press has tried
to make margaret the subject of romance
with 29 year old rodney lewellen but
despite pictures of them in the
caribbean together there has been little
substance to back up the perennial
gossip mongers
[Music]
queen elizabeth has ruled out divorce
for her sister margaret instead the 45
year old princess may obtain a legal
separation from her husband lord snowden
they've been married for 16 years but 10
of those years have reportedly been
stormy and recent stories of princess
margaret's involvement with a 28 year
old jet setter named roddy llewellyn
provide motivation for the current
separation talk
divorce is a thorny subject for the
british royal family
[Music]
she was a divorcee i think and the quest
whether it was
appropriate for the
king of england
to be
married to already was first divorced
[Music]
this is london
a quarterback an hour ago
the prime minister came to the bar of
the house
and handed to the speaker a message from
his majesty the king
a few hours ago
i discharged my last duty as king and
emperor that i have found it impossible
to carry the heavy burden of
responsibility without the help and
support
of the woman i love
we therefore
do now hereby
proclaim
that the high and mighty prince
albert friedrich author george
is now become
our only lawful
and rightful king
god save the cake
[Music]
the two girls were in a house at hyde
park corner
when elizabeth heard
all the noise of the
cheering
when george became king
and
elizabeth ran downstairs to see what all
the excitement was and footman told her
that her father
was king she came back and told her
little sister who was six
and
princess margaret said does that mean
you'll be
queen and she said yes someday
princess margaret said poor you
[Music]
princess margaret has been leading an
active and for royalty a somewhat
untraditional social life
now england is intrigued by the rumor
that margaret has fallen in love
the man is peter townsend a war hero a
captain in the raf
townsend however has been once divorced
and powerful social and religious forces
are marshaled against the romance
still margaret wants to marry townsend
[Music]
invited me to dinner and we talked about
this
very disturbing situation obviously
but the queen i shall never forget her
reaction was one of great sympathy
although no doubt she harmed the
greatest anxiety i expect
marriage seemed to be the least likely
solution
the queen was in conflict because as
head of the church of england she could
not really permit her sister
to marry a divorced man
but as the sister of princess margaret
she obviously was very keen that
princess margaret should be happy
and it wasn't easy
i don't think for a moment that the
queen said to her listen here margaret
you can't do that
the queen would have been told by
advisers that it was not on
very painful for all concerned
it's sometimes been misreported that it
was the queen that said that this
relationship couldn't be allowed
actually she was devastated that when
push came to shove it was the government
who said actually we can't allow you to
marry this man
[Music]
the following statement has just been
issued from clan's house by her royal
highness princess margaret
i would like it to be known that i have
decided not to marry a group captain
peter townsend
mindful of the church's teaching that
christian marriage is indissoluble and
conscious of my duty to the commonwealth
i have resolved to put their
consideration
before any others
i think she had a lot of sympathy for
margaret because after all the queen
knew what true love was she had married
the man of her dreams
[Music]
i don't envy the royals their life at
all really they have to live under the
glare of publicity all the time
everything they do is reported and
quoted and criticized
but princess margaret she had a really
difficult life
i think this is one of the tragedies of
her life that she never knew who she was
never knew who she was supposed to be
and she left it to others not least the
media to work it out for her
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it is a scene of chaos and destruction
this castle dating back to the ninth
century the fire started in the private
chapel miatas and george's fall
the events read like a tabloid redo of
old testament curses plague and
pestilence have been replaced by fire
rumor and outright scandal rocking the
british royal family
with three broken marriages among her
four children the queen's efforts to
promote an image of family harmony are
now under the
strain
look at how the great problems of the
queen and the monarchy in her lifetime
have been all about love and marriage
and sex
the abdication
princess margaret peter townsend later
and that creates problems
[Music]
buckingham palace has condemned the
publication of a series of newspaper
photographs of the duchess of york and
the texan businessman john bryan
[Music]
i just feel very sad i think it's very
sad when two people who
appear to be so happily married quite
suddenly divorced
[Music]
royal composure collapsed as princess
diana under extraordinary media
attention broke down in tears since a
book detailing her unhappiness was
published last week the book claims
diana's marriage became so miserable
that she tried to take her life
[Music]
1992
is not a year
on which i shall look back with
undiluted pleasure
in the words of one of my more
sympathetic correspondence
it has turned out to be
new institution
city
monarchy
whatever
should expect to be free from the
scrutiny of those who give it their
loyalty and
support not to mention those who don't
but we are all part of the same fabric
of our national society
and that scrutiny by one part of another
can be just as effective
if it is made with a touch of gentleness
good humor and understanding
[Music]
as a result of the occurrences over the
course of the past several months and
the pushing of the self-destruct button
by the monarchy
that we could now be witnessing the end
of the monarchy and the reigning queen
could possibly be the last
britain's queen elizabeth said she has
had it it's time for prince charles and
princess diana to officially end their
troubled marriage
the prince who made his televised
admission of adultery over a year ago is
said to agree
the princess who made her televised
admission of adultery a few weeks ago is
said to be devastated and will give her
a response after the holidays
the queen actually tried to
bring diana under her wing but diana was
very reluctant
[Music]
obviously charles couldn't handle it and
neither could the queen
[Music]
the princess of wales embroiled now in a
fresh round of personal controversy the
polo playing former guards officer
claims he had a three-year affair with
the princess this morning as she left
her exclusive london health club the
princess of wales was saying nothing
rugby star will carling and his wife
julia are splitting up and everyone's
asking is the princess of wales to blame
confirmation of princess diana's first
serious romance since her split with
charles will be shown in london's sunday
mirror tomorrow the evidence of
photograph of a kiss with millionaire
dodie fired during a mediterranean
cruise cost four hundred thousand
dollars
this is bbc one we have interrupted our
programs for a news report we now go
over to martin lewis in the news studio
we interrupt this film to tell you we
are getting reports that diana princess
of wales has been badly injured in a car
crash in france
[Music]
just to confirm the news that diana
princess of wales has died in a car
accident in paris which also killed her
companion bloody fired
[Music]
the question a lot of people here in
britain are asking this morning is
where's the queen
the oceans of flowers from diana's
mourners are piling up in front of
buckingham palace but they haven't been
acknowledged and unlike the rest of
britain where the flags are at
half-staff in diana's memory there's no
flag flying over the palace nobody's
home
[Music]
when princess of wales died the queen
was up at belmore with the two little
princes whose mother had been killed
and yet she was passed
for not leaving there
they're coming to london to mourn in the
streets with people who never even let
the people
she had two grandchildren
he must be very caught up with their
mothers one such dead
to
rush them down to london
for the height of this big it seemed
palace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm now looking through the walls of the
shattered school into the main hall
which is a massive people of firemen and
policemen
mothers fathers
brothers and sisters and everybody
[Music]
this south wales disaster
it's now feared that nearly 200 lives
were lost when the cold tip at abervan
near martha tidwell slid forward today
one of the few regrets that the queen
has about her reign was that she felt
that she reacted too slowly in wales at
a place called abbavan back in the 1960s
there's always been a controversy and
criticism
about the queen not actually coming
earlier to abervan or immediately to
abervan because obviously lord snowden
was the first royal to actually come to
abervan princess mark couldn't
understand why i wanted to go down
i just did you know but i i must
and i stayed there
just going into people i was just making
cups of tea
they wanted to talk but they were in a
state of terrible shock
[Music]
so for the queen i think her decision
not to come at that time wasn't probably
the right decision for
surviving people and i think to this day
the queen actually had a bit of guilt
about that herself
[Music]
the queen stood there as a mother
knowing that had circumstances been
somewhat different
her child's name might be fastened to
the sandbag
to mark his place of honor
in death's final ceremonial occasion
i know with all the tragedies in the
world i think abervan has been the main
one that's touched the queen forever and
a day really until the day she dies
[Music]
queen elizabeth and the rest of the
royal family are on summer holiday as
usual in scotland
and apart from a customary trip to
church on sunday the queens made no
public appearance and no public
statement but to those who are close to
the royal family that's no surprise
and if ever the monarchy was it was in
those
48 hours when they were stuck up in
balmoral
when the country wanted the queen in
london and grieving
[Music]
on the eve of princess diana's funeral
the royal family is returning to london
hoping and perhaps to quell some of the
criticism of their actions since diana's
death
the queen's convoy arrived in london as
it swept up to buckingham palace the
limousine halted at the gates and the
queen of prince philip got out to take
in the mass of floral tributes
the queen was actually extremely nervous
because she could feel the hostility and
actually she heard people say oh about
time you've come you know
they can hear an awful lot of things at
the crowd and say and then i think a
woman actually gave her
a bunch of flour and said would you like
me to place it for you and said no mom
it's for you
and that sort of broke the ice it was
that moment
and i think suddenly people saw her
instead of feeling all prickly and angry
they suddenly thought my goodness this
is a grandmother and she's got to deal
with all this
[Music]
queen elizabeth will speak publicly
today about the death of diana princess
of wales joining me from london is npr's
michael goldfarb to talk about the
extraordinary move by the queen to speak
to her subjects any idea what you will
say today
it will be a very carefully crafted
speech because people will listen to it
with great interest
since last sunday's dreadful news
we have seen throughout britain and
around the world
an overwhelming expression of sadness of
diana's death
so what i see to you now as your queen
and as a grandmother
i say from my heart
first i want to pay tribute to diana
myself
she was an exceptional and gifted human
being
in good times and bad
she never lost her capacity to smile and
laugh
nor to inspire others with her warmth
and kindness
i admired and respected her for her
energy and commitment to others
i hope that tomorrow we can all wherever
we are
join in expressing our grief of diana's
loss
and gratitude for her all too short life
i thought she said everything she should
have said i can't think of anything that
she left out until
i think it's completely
[Music]
and they're gathering now at the
entrance
this is an extraordinary
view we're seeing here we've never
as far as i'm aware seen the royal
family standing like this at the gates
of buckingham palace
at the funeral the queen was very
dignified and she bowed her head when
diana's coffin went past
[Music]
and
it was
spectacularly done
i for one believe there are lessons to
be drawn from her life
and from the extraordinary and moving
reaction to her death
it is a chance to show to the whole
world the british nation united in grief
and respect
[Music]
mr speaker today her majesty the queen
becomes the country's longest reigning
monarch and it is of course typical of
her selfless sense of service that she
would have us treat this day just like
any other but mr speaker while i rarely
advocate disobeying her majesty least of
all in our own parliament i do think
it's right that today we should stop and
take a moment as a nation to mark this
historic milestone and to thank her
majesty for the extraordinary service
that she's given to our country over
more than six decades
63 years and 216 days she's worked with
12 prime ministers six archbishops of
canterbury nine cabinet secretaries
she's answered three and a half million
pieces of correspondence send over a
hundred thousand telegrams to
centenarians across the commonwealth and
met more people than any other monarch
in history
she has served this country with
enduring grace dignity and decency and
long nation continue to do so
the important thing to remember about
the early upbringing of princess
elizabeth was that although she was a
princess she was not in line for the
throne
and i believe this gave her a modesty
that
people respect
i think the only thing she might allow
herself to feel
is to say
to her father
look i've done it
i've been queen for such a long time and
i've tried to do it
the way you taught me
there is a motel which has been born by
many of my ancestors
a noble motto
i serve
i should like to make their dedication
now
it is very simple
i declare before you all
with my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be diverted to your service
enter the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you